salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien toutes les semaines on vous
propose un nouveau documentaire sur la
chaîne Youtube de brut et vous pouvez
retrouver tous les liens en description
aujourd'hui je suis super contente de
vous proposer le doc plaisir la
réalisatrice victoire Mabille a
rencontré les inventeurs du womaneniser
en fait c'est un couple allemand
sexagénère qui dans une cabane au fond
de son jardin en Bavière a inventé cet
appareil assez révolutionnaire bon
l'histoire est incroyable je vous laisse
la découvrir et on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
BRI this
prototype maybe in or
[Musique]
weeksend
tempvec
[Musique]
hallo name Michael
lenkeinahre
alt
namegit FRF war test
wom3 hab ich eine amerikanche Studie
gelesen aus der ging hervor dass über
50% der Frauen keinen Höhepunkt
erreichen erstmal schockiert hab GT über
50% also das heißt dass wahrscheinlich
50% der Frauen ihr Mann eigentlich den
Höhepunkt vorspielen und da bin ich
natürlich sch ins Grübel gekommen aber
ich habeagt ne das Brigitte das kann do
nicht sein die kann
nicht mit Frauen disutier an das
lieg50%
fr und ich bin dann langsam auch
dahinter
gekommen das vieles was eigentlich
erzählt wird das ist auch Z ein
vaginalen orgasmus gibt das gar nicht
stimmt es ist immer einitoraler
orgasmus das haben wir Instinktiv
angedacht ein Gerät zu bringen was nicht
invasiv wirkt
seit tausen von Jahren gibt es dild und
davon wollten wir eentlich komplett weg
[Musique]
ich habe mir gedacht okay die man müsste
dieor stimulieren wie es eigentlich beim
filio ist also dieses leichtte saugen
und da wste ich eigentlich dass eine
Frau das lit
erste prototyp Wiz exra ein elektronen
für techn Seite
ich mit
Brigitte
bin mein Ernst ich war gerade
beimügel ich habe gesag ja ichuchte
unbedingt jetzt mal kurzen test macht
mit dem Gerät aber das ist bei ihr erstm
sehr schlecht angekommen aber nach ein
einiger Zeit habe ich
[Rires]
Hal
ah war eine aquariumpumpe umgebaut das
saugdruckfeld erzeugen kann mit schlauch
dran und einem
handstück now
[Rires]
[Musique]
youine ein j gedert und mir Brigitte
dann of leid
getanil manchmal war das F
körperverlzung habe ich gesagt es zur
Seite es tut weh es es ist
unangeh W
dasw
[Musique]
womaniz7 Zeit sehr sehr viele
internationale patente gemacht im
Bereich medizin Elektronik
planzensysteme Erdbeben frühwahysteme
verkehrssicherheitssysteme also querb
bin
[Musique]
ein
ur
die und
manch 30
sekundench einustiges
Produkt für die Angela Merkel
[Musique]
für
den finger in schung bringen kteamit
kosmek
einmieren das Gerät hat leider komplett
gefloppt und dann haben wir aus diesem
ganzen Produkt ein Erotik Produkt
gemacht
[Musique]
das
diese form die wir entwielt haben mit
diesem Gerät habe ich das erste Mal
getestet mit dieser Form als das erste
Mal so richtig funktioniert hat also das
war so unbeschreiblich es war wie ein
ein Gewitter das durch den ganzen Körper
irgendwo geht wo das denken aufhört wo
man nur noch fühl und war ein
wahnsinnserbnis
h war
auchang ein
[Musique]
super herf war wieen wir an Frauen wo
wir testen können und Brigitte hat halt
dann eine eine brilante idee gehabt
undag Mensch wir müssten irgendwo
schau
wir sind dann über eine que von über
93% Erfolg gekommen und dann Wen wir
natürlich dass das eine bom sein wird im
markesti verlau haben wir
dann gr produzien zu Len und ein
internationales marketing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aufubauen wir haben als erstes sind wir
nach Hong Kong und wir sind nobudies und
wir sind einfach auf der messe mit einem
Riesen messestand erschienen mit dem
können wir eine orgasmusgarantie geben
und man hat halt uns
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
belächelt und es sind viele einkäufer
von großen internationalen Unternehmen
zu uns gekommen und den haben wir ein
ger mitgegeben abends zum testen die
haben meistens ihre Frauen dabe gehabt
und s dann
Hotel und anderenag war die schon vor
messe vor unserem
standestanden und bitte können wir
sofort ein vertriebsvertrag für USA oder
für Europa
[Musique]
machen die Schweiz FT die hitliste an
und dann
die
Frankreich auch sehr gut aber spanien
italien griechenland wo die Männer noch
matchos sind trauen sich die Frauen
nicht so weil die Männer doch sehr sehr
viel einfluss haben und wenn dann eine
Frau sagt oh ich möchte so wer wird
problem haben die kauften sich ohne dass
es der Mann weiß das wisen wir 30 bis
40% Frauen
W
wear
AC also Wen mich fr ob ich vor 20ahen an
gedachtätte dass ich geworden bin und
auch
meine zchauer hat sich unser Leben
eigentlich
dahingehend Geert dass wir mehr Zeit für
uns haben
Brach maises sœurs entendez-moi on dira
un truc qui fait une sonde qui envoie
les sondes sur les
monstres ton
voil bruit qu' fait allez tiens ça se
que sur [__] en fait ça se met sur le
[__] et ça vibre comme ça ouais c'est
ça ou ça l'pire je crois ouire en fait
suivant la taille de ton [__] ou s il
est très caché sur le capuchon ou pas tu
en as des différents en fait soit des
plus grands des plus petits des beaucoup
plus intenses par exemple qui est très
sensible peut-être que ça c'est trop
fort que je vois ce que jeux dire ouais
déjà sur la main je trouve que c'est
particulier j'imagine enfin j'aimerais
voir comment ça se fait sur le Coutau ça
peut te faire jouir très
rapidement il veut plus se décoller
voilà ça vous parle ouais il m'en a
offert un un peu comme
ça bah du coup je je les teste
c'est clairement pas le truc magique
pour moi
mais mais c'est intéressant on va dire
c'est c'est quelque chose qui est
faudrait utiliser ensemble ce que
j'allais dire j'aimerais bien qu'on
l'utilise à deux qu'on a pas fait ça que
justement ça ça fasse partie du de la
panoplie leses t les les outils
possibles à notre
disposition la boîte à outil ça marche
trop avec tout cette
image en fait c'est un truc qui est très
ciblé sur ton kitoris donc en fait c'est
un plaisir qui va être très intense très
rapide et effectivement tu vas avir une
retombée du coup très enfin c'est un
truc qui ça fait tac ça fait sexo
d'appoint tu vois que oui c'est un truc
très rapide très tu vois ce que je veux
dire gen en mode tu vas pas prendre
temps c'est tout à fait ça franchement
j'ai pas trouvé ça c'était cool tu vois
mais c'était pas je crois
[Musique]
que en vrai enfin je je mentirais si je
dirais non mais parce que par exemple tu
vois ça ça m'a fait squorter tu vois ce
que je veux dire c'est une action
mécanique de ton corps donc ça activit
mécaniquement mon squirt non mais
simulation externe ça reste quand même
une avancée de [__] ça y est on a
enfin un Seto qui est que pour ça
quoi je trouve que rien qu'au niveau de
la forme on voit que c'est fait pour un
clitoris j'ai pu tester ce genre de de
sex toys une fois et le plaisir est
vraiment vraiment ouf enfin on a
l'impression qu'on a plus besoin de
personne avec ça quoi c'est tu tu as ça
c'est bon c'est fini tu as tes orgasmes
garantis et et tu es bien donc j'aime
bien quand j'ai commencé à à me
masturber pour la première fois c'était
aussi en même temps la première fois que
je touchais vraiment mon vagin je
m'installe dans mon lit et je me dis bah
on va essayer de tester les sensations
que ça pourrait me donner et là je suis
soulagée je me dis ça y est c'est fait
j'ai eu mon premier orgasme ça marche et
c'est peut-être à ce moment-là au final
que je réalise vraiment
que j'ai un vagin pour moi la
masturbation c'est un
truc que je fais pas très très souvent
je sais pas l'idée l'idée de me
masturber me gênait même si je sais que
personne regardait et que c'était un
truc toute seule dans mon coin mais ça
enfin c'était moi avec moi-même mais
après j'ai des souvenirs aussi de enfin
à cette époque là pendant l'adolescence
de fill autour de moi qui en parlait et
qui par exemple trouvait ça dégueulasse
enfin c'est des des des des choses que
j'ai pu entendre au moment où où j'ai pu
commencer en fait je pense que pour la
masturbation c'est tabou complet j'ai
cru jusqu'à assez tard que les filles ne
se masturbaient pas mais c'est-à-dire au
moins jusqu'au lycée jusqu'à la fin du
lycée parce que c'était un c'était un
truc de
mec et on en parlait avec des amis et
c'était les mecs ça se masturbe et les
filles ça ne se masturbe pas et j'avais
beaucoup j'avais beaucoup beaucoup
d'amis filles euh avec qui on avait pas
des discussions assez ouvertes pour
parler de ces choses-là mais qui
néanmoins m'avait laissé entendre que
non non les filles ça se masturbent pas
c'était comme tu disais un peu
dégueulasse ou je sais pas perso
perso vous avez commencé à vous
masturber genre vers quel âge tôt en
vrai tôt mais tu sais pas ce que c'est
moi c à 3
ans voilà je raelle la Grande Section
Matern
non peut-être pas du cou tu as 4 ans 4 5
ans tu t'en souviens ouais men souviens
ouais je m'en souviens vraiment c'est
quoi ton genre vraiment c'était un bon
euh
dans dans la cour et j'is comme ça sur
le ban comme ça tu je t'imagine le truc
tu vois et j'ai toujours eu des
l'impression de me masturber pas comme
il fallait parce que le porno et
beaucoup de choses font que on a
l'impression du coup que la femme doit
se murber de telle manière sur le dos
avec des doigts dans sa chatte voilà non
mais vraiment après c'est bien de le
faire comme ça c'est ok mais tu sais
quand tu te masturbes d'une façon
différente de toute façon on a toute
l'impression de pas se masturber de la
bonne manière c'est normal mais là
c'était un truc moi c'était sans contact
genre même il fallait je sois habillé
sans contact sans contact manuel genre
je pouvais être je pouvais être habill
c'est fou que c'est fou que pour toi
c'était aussi fréquent et libéré parce
que pour le coup moi je sais que pareil
j'ai commencé très tôt à masturber mais
ça restait
très très intime genre je le cachais et
personne nétait au courant j'en parlais
PASF et ça a continué comme ça jusquà au
moins l'adolescence jusqu'au jour où
j'ai décidé d'assumer que ouais ok je
m'assure mais c'est OK en fait genre
voilà ah
ouais il y a le fameux
Womanizer ça c'est la
W ça en fait c'est supposé être une
version améliorée du
cuni un peu un de mes préférés est-ce
que je peux l'allumer je crois qu'on l'a
je crois qu'on a [__] la batterie bah
c'est la preuve que c'est le préféré du
coup je me masturbis pour faire comme
les autres ça marchait pas du tout je
suis devenue une super bonne menteuse
j'allais choper des anecdotes à droite à
gauche de ce que j'entendais des gens
j'allais sur internet et je
cherchaisah quels étaient les symptômes
de l'orgasme donc après j'enisais des
caisses je disais que moi je je
tremblais j'avais chaud après j'avais
des fourmis dans tout le corps enfin CIT
n'importe quoi et j'étais devenue un peu
la référence autour de moi de la meuf
qui avait les meilleurs orgasmes et et
me demander comment est-ce que je
faisais pour y arriver je disis
n'importe quoi
aussi je pas vous mais moi au lycée on
avait beaucoup la pression sur comment
tu cries oh trop bizarre ouais mais si
je trouve qu'il y avait ce truc de tu
voors parce qu'en fait quand tu jou
quand tu cries pas assez c'est que c'est
pas bien si tu cries trop tu es une
criarde enfin tu vois ce que je veux
dire il y a une façon de jouir sexy
exactement puis de crier sexy trouve cri
non mais même de gênir sexy tu pas ça
non mais ça me termine parce que une
fois j'étais en train de faire avec
quelqu'un et et je faisais du du coup il
dis mais c'est ouf il a écru'était
me tu mets pas en mute quoi ça va pas je
me Seris tellement énervé é
aussi
aujourd'ui le premier orgasme je
recevais un colis donc c'est un sex qui
vibre très fort et c'est la première
fois que j'avais une stimulation
clitoridienne qui fonctionnait et j'ai
découvert euh que j'étais capable de
jouir que j'étais capable d'avoir un
orgasme donc je n'avais absolument pas
honte c'éit une chouette première
fois
[Applaudissements]
oui ah
oui j'ai honte de le dire oui pas de
doute est-ce que c'est une
question le pire c'est qu'on se simule
pour que ça se finisse ouais ouais ou
alors c'est parce que tu vois qu'il
essaye
tellement allez t'inquiète au début dans
les rapports sexuels on prend pas de
plaisir enfin moi je me souviens que
déjà de gérer truc ouis quand on est au
collège ou au lycée tout le monde dit oh
c'est un truc de ouf et tout puis en
plus on nous fait voir des pornos du
coup ça a une bonne pub on nous fait
comprendre que surtout la meilleure
façon de de faire l'amour c'est avec un
pénis dans tous les cas si je veux jouir
si je veux avoir une belle vie sexuelle
c'est il va me pilonner tu vois et ça
c'est un bon sexe tu vois un mec qui
s'occupe pas de ton [__] tu vois pas
trop l'intérêt so là tu vois ce que je
veux dire mais quand on était peut-être
plus jeune comme il y avait moins cette
conscience de l'importance du clitoris
on tolérait savent pas un jour j'ai eu
un rapport avec un gars alors on se
chauffe très longtemps et on vient au
fait donc il fait ses vaill bien lui il
kiffe et tout puis là j'tais mais mais
c'est ça en fait non mais non mais genre
j'avais l'impression queil y avait juste
un bâton genre eu un truc à l'intérieur
de moi genre
ah et puis après il Ain donc du coup il
il éjacule il s'enfuit à la salle de
bain'' non non
non j'aime bien ou c'est beau c'est
c'est précis c'est non non je veux dire
donc il jouit donc du coup il va se
nettoyer et puis je reste bloqué comme
ça sur le canapé en me disant mais mais
en fait c'est pas si ouf que ça moi je
ressens toutes les sensations quand je
me fais pénétrer ou Léchet c'est la même
chose tout est pareil le vagin d'une
femme tror est recréé à partir des
composants du pénis donc le gland
devient un clitoris la pénis devient la
peau des lèvres et le vagin d'une femme
transjor ressemble au vagin d'une femme
si genor les terminaisons nerveuses sont
là pareil c'est la même chose le premier
ça a été je pense le meilleur orgasme de
ma vie et la chance que j'ai eu moi
c'est que du coup je peux m'en souvenir
très bien parce que c'était il y a un an
et c'était magique et c'était le le
commencement de de quelque chose de
nouveau pour moi se faire pénétrer ça
fait du bien en tout cas dans mon cas
mais c'est surtout aussi pour l'échange
que j'ai avec le partenaire quand je le
fais et en échange que je retrouverai
pas du coup avec des
sextiles c'est pas humain quoi
[Musique]
ern sich die Ziele lafen hat daer neue
Ideen und will was verändern
im Moment habe ich ein ser gr proek Lauf
das ist ja
einnert se
fürutoma
bluf danned programme auch
[Rires]
durch
[Musique]
inqute
pas c'est vrai que ça m'a traversé lespr
un quart de seconde être comme ça
maintenant
[Musique]
déshabillez-vous j'espère que mon père
passti il a Brux
il a ou ah ben dis donc surprise mais
enfin mais en même temps je suis pas sûr
que ce soit les gens qui regardent
naturellement je pense pas on n pas vie
en soldat et il y a pas
[Musique]
d'explosion voilà j'espère vraiment que
ça vous a plu et un grand grand merci à
Victoire Mabille Stéphanie cockel et
toutes les équipes de brut qui ont
participé à ce documentaire alors
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
Youtube de brut pour ne rien manquer des
prochaines vidéos et documentaires et
moi je vous dis à
bientôt